[Music]
anyway yeah i went to monster jam
[Laughter]
oh yeah how was that cash was there it
was
it was a very scary
scary why
it's just an interesting place
to be honest some some of the crowd was
just like at some moments it was at the
angel stadium at some moments you felt
like you're just you're at a baseball
game it's like a
you know mixed crowd the part that
really reminded me that we were at a
monster truck show was the sheer amount
of kids
[Music]
i posted when some dude respond to my
story he's like i remember this was cool
when i was six i'm like well i'm 16 and
it's still cool so [ __ ] you and then
there's a bunch of kids with their
parents drinking that lets you know that
you're a monster truck kids are drinking
they look like it i mean they're just
sitting with tall cans in like the
[ __ ] cup holder and you're not sure
if it's theirs or their parents um with
these two dudes behind us oh man
oh man their brains only worked out loud
it was
[ __ ] hilarious what were they saying
the worst [ __ ] ever ever everything bad
you can think of just picture two guys
that wore metal militia in high school
now they're 34 and they hate their kids
so they were talking [ __ ] about their
kids to their kids about the show wow
there was one woman driver and you know
oh no they gave it to her
oh yeah yeah she was out there trying to
show out and they're like it came to the
freestyle round or something and they
just kept saying like yeah she's got no
balls to do it man because they're
referring to the backflip everyone that
night was trying to backflip their
trucks
they couldn't nail it
at that moment that you know that night
kind of gave me the same feeling i think
people get from wrestling because the
whole night everyone attempted to
backflip and actually the woman driver
was the second closest one she actually
got her truck to rotate a couple times
she couldn't land it it was crazy
because you know the one and only
gravedigger went out there put on a show
and did he backflip first of all the
dudes that drive for that franchise like
i don't know what they teach them that's
different from the other people but you
could tell they come from the old school
they have no hesitancy like they pull
the truck out they put it exactly where
they want to start they back it up and
then when they hit the throttle it's
just nonstop those guys the way they
drive is like they land they pitch the
car on 180 and they're back up in the
air
they get [ __ ] high
like that part i didn't anticipate i'm
talking like two three stories in the
air i'm like i don't know how the [ __ ]
you do that so whatever gravedigger's
just killing it
we're like whoa you know me i'm getting
ready to
dig the invisible trench i'm like yeah
bring my man to first place he has puts
on this stellar performance and he goes
to approach the backflip and his he
[ __ ] he goes and he gets the truck up
and then he [ __ ] hits neutral with
like his elbow or something and then so
the the truck just like dies and like
falls on its head
so everyone's like
so he was first she didn't have the
balls man so he was first then the lady
driver goes out you know she don't have
no balls
oh she's a lady
careful she's gonna hit the
parking meter well you know she did like
a 360 and you could hear all the guys
there like typical woman going in
circles you know
everything you'd expect
oh that's funny yeah not funny like i'm
not saying yeah yeah yeah i'm saying
it's women are funny no no no no classic
driver misogyny yeah and sexism from
like 30 years ago her run learn how to
read a map
she her run was off to like a decent
start and then she [ __ ] lands the
truck like the center of the truck like
on a big ass mound and then you know
because the two guys behind us no no
cars better than women
[Laughter]
first of all those guys all night would
say some [ __ ] was wrong with the truck
and it's not what was wrong with okay
but uh like one guy like his truck just
kind of like he landed and it just like
it wouldn't start so his run was over
and they're like yeah dude he [ __ ]
tried to land it in reverse like you
can't do that
and all of us were like how do you know
that
and then one of them was like dude he
broke the [ __ ] axle and i'm sitting
there like a nerd like actually that's
the rear differential so the woman like
lands her car and she has to stop the
run because i didn't realize like when
they drive that the cabin is open so
whatever like gets [ __ ] up goes up
into their seat okay so she has like a
piece of [ __ ] debris that she's like
kicking out of the
truck and then someone actually had to
run out and pull it out so they pull it
out and she lines up to do the back flip
lands it
no way no i'm she she rotated the truck
oh damn i was into that she she gets it
up she rotates it like a couple times
and lands on her head but she got the
closest so the [ __ ] crowd goes nuts
and the crowd votes
like their score she gets placed ahead
of gravedigger whoa
the whole stadium was
pissed dude
not happy what was her name cara that
was her car's name oh no no her she
drove like her car make up shopping or
something it was soldier fortune yeah
makeup yeah yeah oh what like cookie
bakery girl
yeah her shit's like army themed it's a
dope-ass car i mean yeah it is no it's a
cool car it just felt like definitely
like a brand deal in the middle of it
all right whatever so she goes out she
she lands that so then the last dude in
the lineup is the word the
son of a gravedigger that's like the
literal son of the original gravedigger
driver and it's kind of cheating because
the gravedigger franchise they basically
have two cars on the grid yeah so if one
of them [ __ ] up it's like they can
still protect a family name
so that boy goes out there [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] it up going nuts and did he do
the backflip bruh so he has this crazy
ass run he did some crazy [ __ ] earlier
in the night where he was like up on two
wheels around the corner just like
babied it just whatever dope ass run and
he goes up to the back flip everyone's
like holding their breath they're like
huh huh he does it he lands it and then
on landing he crashes into gravedigger
and he pops a tire out so it's like the
ultimate like
he's trashed the car on the land
[ __ ] stadium's going crazy he like
hops out the [ __ ] rips off his helmet
he's like kicking the tire he's like
back to the [ __ ]
i'm the [ __ ] man and then you know
the whole stadium's like get her out
getting on plane oh my god dude
so then you know we all get uh we're
digging the trench we're like
but you know i watched all that and then
i thought this is cool but they just
need to get some of those dudes from
like like the dubai drifting videos i
think those guys would put on a better
show because they get an accord like
sideways you know on the freeway yeah if
they gave them that [ __ ] they're like
bruh there'd be one wheel just spinning
it's just like a top dude
yeah they would have like yeah and they
do this [ __ ] with like bugattis too yeah
and you name it they don't care they
know what they're doing you know these
dudes i'm like i feel like they could
they have the brain capacity to drive a
car like each individual tire balancing
on top too yeah that's what i want to
see monster jam is kind of in a bubble
because their talent pool is very
exclusive i think they need to open it
up to the world there needs to be a
formula one of monster jam where it's
like drivers from all over yeah is it
dangerous monster gym yeah um i mean
like when you crash or land upside down
like no
the [ __ ] the the frame underneath is
so stiff it is nuts we were watching
them like as you drive by when they
shift the gears the whole like
the driver is like glued to it okay it's
pretty intense basically i say all that
to say like we should just quit this and
start driving monster trucks oh okay
yeah i think we'd be really good at it
i'm down
honestly you know youtube's hitting the
[ __ ] yeah just switch it up so yeah
like i said before iterating is
important yeah pushing yourself yeah so
monster truck driving i think is next on
the chopping block also it's kind of
like wrestling in that like all the
drivers have to get out and do like
these post drive interviews and they
refer to everyone as the fans because
they don't want to acknowledge that it's
all kids okay but like they have to
you know they have to like give a speech
and they're like man the fans out here
showing love show love for zombie
there's a dr the truck named zombie and
all the kids would go like this okay
they have a whole stadium